you
[Music]
if I were to rank perhaps the top 20
individuals would help to shape the
world around us I think Albert Einstein
would be on that short list kings and
queens they come and go
Emperor's and empresses well they beef
almost no trace in the footprints of
history but Albert Einstein's work
resonates throughout history even today
people ask the question when as Einstein
done for me lately and the answer is
everything
everything we see around us the
electronics the satellites the atom
smashers all of that in some sense can
be traced back to the work of Albert
Einstein in fact many of the crumbs the
crumbs from his table have gone on to
win Nobel prizes for physicists even
today